I I have to be honest and say there are
times when I think
golly you know I want to be in the
Limelight I mean I don't think of it in
those terms but that that does kind of
well up every now and then but it's
nothing that uh is
um a driving force inside me Cindy
Williams has died following a short
illness and in the wake of her death
Hollywood is paying tribute you fell as
mine if we girls go to the ladies room
and freshen up a bit first I'm already
Fresh La Verne how fresh and I'll make
you happy shortly after news broke of
the actress's death at the age of 75 her
former co-stars chimed in like Ron
Howard who starred alongside her in
Happy Days and American Graffiti
what for
and I can get tough with you too you
know
hard guy the actor spoke to ET about his
long time to friend quote I remember her
life spark and her and her energy I saw
her last year in Palm Springs at an
event and still saw that sparkle in her
eyes it's so hard to imagine that she's
gone we just brought a spirit like a
camp you know Spirit to it and and I
think that was one of the things that
um
uh that caused the movie to have that
feeling of
it's just like everybody's story you
know everybody could relate to it Ron
adds Cindy wanted to be remembered for
her range of characters that she created
different tones and different styles
Cindy had so much talent and she settled
for none of the Hollywood traffic she
just did her work please smile
[Music]
Summers who had
a three film also recalled working with
Cindy quote loved my time hanging in the
trailer with her on the set of American
Graffiti and then the fabulous Tuesday
night lineup on ABC Laverne and Shirley
Happy Days and Three's Company we had
good times together rest in peace dear
dear friend there's a feeling of
camaraderie within the movie and a
feeling of of everybody really knowing
everyone Cindy's Laverne and Shirley
co-stars are also honoring her Legacy
artery
[Music]
it really stinks
in a statement to E.T Michael McKean
said Cindy was so talented and so game
when she and Penny were cooking there's
no one who could touch them the happiest
time was when you hit a joke perfectly
and you heard that audience laugh Henry
Winkler AKA The Fonz
remembered the first time he met Cindy
on the set of Happy Days this is burn
DeFazio She's mine and this is Shirley
Feeney she's yours as you can see the
actor tells E.T quote not once have I
ever been in her presence when she
wasn't gracious thoughtful and kind
Cindy's Talent was Limitless there was
not a genre she could not conquer I am
so glad I knew her I want to tell you
about your day okay and she's a very
cute girl but she's not your usual type
of girl
Anson Williams who played potsy on the
sitcom told E.T he's devastated by her
laws quote the only thing bigger than
her Talent was her heart she walked the
Walk of kindness a giver never a taker a
star who made everyone she touched a
bigger Star as you get older things in
your past become treasures and you get
sentimental about them and I was
thinking the other day oh why am I
crying over Laverne and Charlie it was a
comedy but it was just all those
beautiful beautiful moments that you you
know when you're younger they pass by
and I think this is how God intended it